this one man I've been waiting to talk
to you Mike Adam hits digital this
Friday and obviously Shazam Fury of the
Gods is in theater so let's do some
rapid fire questions if you guys are
cool with that yeah of course what have
been some of your favorite memories
working uh together behind the scenes I
mean we have finally landed exactly
where we need to be honestly I nothing
is coming to mind
for sure yeah um who do you think would
win in a fight between the two of you I
mean your characters
so I would well my favorites real quick
you can't use lightning those rules
this person is trying to harm me my
people my loved ones
you die that's it wow you're walking
around like an 85 year old version of
yourself
I mean maybe it's because I try as best
I can I try to keep a perspective of
gratitude and enjoying it I feel really
confident in the new leadership I'm
being told